¿Ves esto que parece un simple bulto en
la ancía? Pues no es un granito, no es
una inflamación sin más, es un abso
dental, un flemón. Y lo que hay dentro
es push, una acumulación de bacterias,
tejido muerto e infección que
normalmente empieza por algo que mucha
gente ignora durante meses. Una caries
profunda, una infección en la raíz del
diente, una muela rota o incluso una
encía infectada. El problema es que el
cuerpo intenta defenderse encerrando
toda esa infección en una especie de
bolsa y cuando la presión aumenta
aparece el dolor brutal, la inflamación
de la cara, el mal sabor, el pus incluso
fiebre. Y no, los antibióticos por sí
solos muchas veces no solucionan el
problema porque si el pus está atrapado
hay que drenarlo. Por eso, en este caso
hacemos una pequeña apertura para
liberar toda la infección acumulada y
despresurizar la zona. Y aunque el
alivio suele ser inmediato, esto no
termina aquí. Después hay que tratar la
causa real, hacer una endodoncia, tratar
la infección o incluso extraer el diente
si ella no puede salvarse, porque si no
se elimina el origen, el abstceso
vuelve. Y sí, una infección dental no
tratada puede llegar a extenderse por la
cara, el cuello e incluso convertirse en
algo serio. Así que no ignores un flemón
pensando que ya se pasará o me voy a
tomar antibióticos y ya está, porque a
veces la boca avisa demasiado tarde.